alright guys bangbang super excited to
have Robin here we got a whole bunch of
stuff to get through so thanks for doing
this great to see you
absolutely I don't have a cap on so only
reason I have one on is because I
haven't gotten a haircut in a while well
I haven't either I maybe I should
actually put the cap on think I'll get a
haircut next week I'm scheduled finally
to get another one so perfect let's uh
let's start with just your background so
those that don't know you you've done a
ton of different things maybe kind of
give us a cuz I'm old I'm old let's make
sure they know that too I like to say
it's not old it's experienced right well
it's both old comes with a bunch of
things including experience and wisdom
but some other negatives too short so I
started out long long ago as an
undergraduate engineering and then I
thought where I was it was two cookbooks
so I switched to physics and then I got
a physics undergrad but then I decided
to go off and do philosophy of science
for grad school but then after two years
I decided oh I'd learned what I needed
to know about philosophy of science the
deep questions I answered enough I
switched back to physics to get a
master's in physics and master's
philosophy science then I read some
stuff about cool stuff happening in
Silicon Valley about artificial
intelligence and hypertext publishing
they call it the web that was before
there was a web and so I went out to
Silicon Valley I worked at Lockheed
because it's the first job I could find
for a couple years and then I switched
to NASA and so for nine years I did
computer research in Silicon Valley and
then I've been doing all nah institution
design as a hobby on the side I finally
decided to try to make a career out of
that so I went to Caltech where
initially I plan to do experiments
because we physicists respect
experiments but then I learned that you
really can't do experiments there unless
you have a theory
they don't just test institutions they
test a theory of an institution so I
learned to do more theory I learned lots
of things that I didn't realize social
scientists know because this is don't
believe social scientists know anything
and even computer scientists I guess
don't believe that so much
I spent you know four years getting a
PhD at Caltech in social science I did a
two-year health policy postdoc at UC
Berkeley and then I got my job here in
1999 where I've been you know for 21
years here and along the way I on the
side did some things in the great filter
sort of you know aliens and
extraterrestrial life and dabbled in a I
have a book called the elephant in the
brain with a co-author that's classified
as psychology I have a book the age of M
that's seen as futurism and so I've
really done a wide range of things more
so than academic academic rewards
academia mostly rewards you for being
very been the best person in the world
and a very narrow specialty and I didn't
do that and I got away with it
luckily and the thing I'm most known for
is prediction markets betting markets on
things but I'm known for a lot of things
so one of my questions is like you went
down so many different paths right and
you've got a greater level of expertise
or experience on those different paths
than most but you kept seeking out other
paths to go down or other disciplines
and so what was really the driving force
behind building that expertise and
experience across so many disciplines
well have excuses and perhaps real
reasons so if I stand away from myself
and don't look inside myself and just
say you know why would might do person
do that I observed that most
intellectuals when they fail they fail
for failing to sufficiently focus these
most ordinary people when they indulge
themselves and intellectual things they
spread themselves out broadly and even
people who are trying to get a peach
jeez they still are tempted to spread
themselves out pretty broad because it's
just really interesting and so you know
they people like to be broad
intellectually and they have to learn to
be narrow if they want to succeed so
that's the most obvious plausible
explanation for me this but I'm like
everybody else and I didn't know it was
I didn't do what was good for me and I
sort of screwed by now I can justify
this
giving some benefits from it so
certainly one thing I did was to keep
asking myself how important is this
thing I'm working on and can I see
something else more important and to
keep switching when I thought something
else was more interesting important you
know bigger and most intellectuals they
sort of grab first thing they they seem
to have some success at they don't ask
that question how important is this
compared to other things and so the work
that intellectuals do varies enormously
in its value because people are not sort
of surveying widely and choosing the
most important interesting things they
are doing whatever they can wrap and the
world itself isn't doing that survey
it's basically opportunistically you
know old funding people who seem
impressive I can also say that I think
of the strategy of looking for
combinations of things and and
intersections that are interesting is a
useful intellectual strategy that
requires that you look at a lot of
things so the only people who could
really play that game are people who do
look at a lot of things and
interestingly it has a scale economy of
the more things you know the more
intersections you can find and so
compared to some other strategies it
Peaks later in life yes your energy of
looking for lots of things at
intersecting them I'm still thinking I'm
rising on that trajectory even though my
many of my abilities of the client my
overall productivity at finding
interesting intersections is still going
up yeah and I forget the name of the
book I think it might have been range
where misty talks about this idea like
being a generalist is actually an
advantage rather than early in life
getting a very specific focus and
becoming a deep expert on one thing
having that kind of more rounded type
approach can serve as a significant
advantage later in life that is a good
book and you know it's it's giving a
middle ground it's saying people often
over specialize that they believe they
should over especially so humans are
relatively general creatures you know
we're compared to most other animals
like us we took this generalist niche
and that's worked very well for us it
works better when the environments are
changing more
in some sense generalists should work
better and more in the modern world than
in ancient worlds that were more stable
the slower things are changing than the
more by specializing you could win by
you know picking something out but and
that's a big issue in our world today a
lot of things change a lot but I think
actually many of our institutions are
not flexible enough because they have
got stuck in a stable world I think
we're seeing that in the pandemic
response and in many other ways the
longer your world is stable then the
more your institutions and habits are
tempted to sort of assume the recent
pattern and specialize for that recent
pattern and then when you have a shock
and a change it's much harder to adapt
so for example in the pandemic the
nations that have been changing the most
recently and that have dealt with
problems like this more recently I've
just done a lot better because they're
more flexible so you've been all over
the virus right in terms of very early
on calling hey this is bigger than we
think this is gonna get out of China you
know a bunch of things that now we know
as fact but at the time you were early
to see that maybe just give us at a
10,000 foot view like what has
transpired since the end of last year to
today with the virus both good and bad
and kind of not only the events that
have occurred but also the responses
from various governments well so it
showed up initially in China initially
Chinese repressed news and let it get
farther than it should've but then they
switched around and did a strong heroic
suppression and managed to keep it
suppressed not only in Wuhan were
dropped but prevented it from spreading
to the rest of China substantially
heroic and strong an expensive effort
and the rest of the world didn't
sufficiently keep it from leaving China
unfortunately and so you know the ideal
thing would have been if the rest of the
world had just locked down you know
traveling from China and you know
testing and things like that then it
would have stopped to that and a great
many other pandemics have been stopped
at that very early stage and that's
overwhelmingly the
cost-effective point at which you want
to deal with it is just to make a stop
at the beginning but many governments
failed to to stop it from spreading to
the other places now some of the initial
places that failed and then you know
like South Korea for example they had an
you know an initial problem outside of
China but then they did a heroic strong
effort and managed to suppress it there
and some other places in the area
did you know pretty strong efforts of
grabbing and initially and stopping it
like Hong Kong Taiwan but it's a big
world and a key thing to know about a
pandemic is when you have any sort of
growth process when you average a bunch
of different growth processes the total
really is dominated by the fastest
growth process of the set so that it
doesn't that much matter what the median
place does it matters what the worst
place to us and when you add up the
total the worst place dominates at least
an unless you could sort of isolate them
from each other and you know mean that
one one hits a maximum the other place
is nothing the fact it's so but so it's
a big world that's spread around the
world and some places did better than
others but of course the basic problem
is wherever does worse that makes a lot
of cases those people go elsewhere and
that spreads and so that's what we've
seen so far is that even though many
places have done very well the worst
places have dominated and now the u.s.
is kind of one of the worst places we're
we're the guilty party and not overall
of the USA
New York and a few places they dominated
the total effect because again it's not
about the middle place and how well it
does it's about the worst place and how
well it does how badly it does and so
you know initially public health
officials when they saw it escaped China
they said to themselves reasonably I
guess that's it
this is gonna go most everywhere and
that's what I said I said [ __ ] I even
said it I thought as it seemed to be
escaping for move on so I guess I was a
little early I was I said look it's
going outside of Wuhan that's it and the
rest of China did manage surprising to
me to keep it down but then it went to
the rest of the world and so public
health people said that's it I guess
we'll have to deal with this going most
everywhere because public health people
have a lot of experience with the
diseases and basically nothing has ever
spread that far and then been contained
and so they were perfectly reasonable to
expect that that would happen here but
when they've said things like we need to
flatten the curve spread it out so that
there's not too much impact at any one
moment for the medical system and the
rest of our systems then the elites in
the world said no they said no no this
has to be contained so they had suddenly
woken up and decided that even though
initially they screwed up and sort of
the United States the health officials
really badly screwed up CDC in terms of
preventing testing preventing masks for
a whole bunch of things you can read
about how badly you screwed up for a
month there but then once everybody was
once the elites in the world were
concerned about this and talked about
the concern everybody said no no we have
to we can't give up on this we must
contain and so ever since then you know
that that was you know three months ago
the elites of the world that we must
contain and they started writing white
papers and doing analysis and saying
well look some places have contained you
know in South Korea Taiwan Hong Kong and
many places have contained and here
we're not doing the good job but we
ought to be able to do a better job
because how could they be better than us
and they listed out well what we need a
lot more testing and we know more ways
to do tasks me a lot more tracing and
maybe apps and different we need to hire
more people and we need more rules about
isolation and we need more masks and you
know people went while talking about all
the things they thought we should do and
all the different big things if we did
them then that should be enough because
hey there's other
that are succeeding but the fact is we
haven't actually gone very far in those
directions for whatever reasons we
haven't now you know one way to think
about it this is to say look policy's
complicated and it's less about each
little piece than having good packages
so different countries in the world just
have whole different governance systems
and whole different strategies and all
different resources and I would think if
you saw some places or working at other
places aren't and you wanted to win your
best strategy would be to pick the
package that works somewhere and just
slavishly copy that whole package I mean
that is how innovation tends to work in
the world if you think you know some
company like GM is successful and you
don't know what about them as
successfully you just try to copy the
whole cultural package all the little
pieces and you think you're gonna try to
be like no unfortunately that's not what
people did they didn't say let's copy
South Korea or less copy Taiwan they
said we here in our different place
we're gonna do our our package that
makes sense to us and they all different
different packages and now they're all
in different places and even today when
we see our package isn't working so well
we aren't tempted to do the radical
let's now go to South Korea package or
something even and then even that it
might not be feasible anymore in the
sense that we might be to past an early
stage where certain things work with the
early stage for going to work later and
so we still got all these people saying
if only you would follow my profit we
would all succeed but they're not all
behind something so initially back in
you know they're very march the elites
all got behind this story we're all
going to lock down and we're all going
to beat this thing but they let
everybody say well you choose your own
life you choose your own style and your
own everything and now if they would all
say no we need the South Korea package
or whatever it is and all get behind
that and say and here's the budget and
we're gonna spend a lot and you know
we're just gonna do it
we would all probably go along with it
and that might work but we're not the
elites are not like behind one common
package they're spread across a dozen
different like priorities and what
things we should be focused on and
they're doesn't see me much of a move
to change the overall policies and and
after this initial people were going
down a bit but of course Li the problem
was we're not going down very fast so I
mean the two key outcomes for a pandemic
are it spreads and everybody gets it
everybody gets exposed or it's contained
and squashed down to a low enough level
that then the traditional methods of
testing traits can keep it down that
still can be expensive but those are the
options but hanging out in the middle
doesn't get you anywhere and in fact if
you spend a lot to hang out in the
middle you're doing worse than going in
either direction for sure and so I guess
that brings two questions right one is
do you think what South Korea Taiwan and
other countries who have you know done
quote a good job is it sustainable can
they continue to do that or do they kind
of expend all the resources and can't
continue that's still an open question
that is you know if the whole world
contained it then we could all rest and
have it be contained and then open our
borders to each other and trade and
travel because all the other places
would all swap contain it the problem is
again when we have variety and it's
dominated by the worst then even if most
places have contained it then if the
place if places haven't and then it you
know goes wild there and we get a lot of
people affected then you have to close
your borders to them and all the people
that they were be open to until some
strong treatment is by so obviously many
people are hoping for a strong treatment
like a vaccine but that probably many
years away and may never come and so you
have to be prepared to do whatever
you're doing for a long time so we're
facing this prospect that say there'll
be two kinds of nations in the world the
ones that have contained it the ones
that happened and they can't be opened
up to each other right and we'll have
two groups of trading and travelling
partners and these ones who are locked
down
they're the ones afraid of the other
side and the question is how long can
they maintain those borders especially
say in the United States I mean between
countries it's easier to imagine
maintaining borders like Australia or
New Zealand Islands far away you could
manage those borders because we have
traditionally managed national borders
but within the United States say it's
really hard to imagine California
putting up the borders so those people
from New York comics ever I mean so then
what can California do if California
manages to keep cases down and New York
doesn't unless they can find a way to
put up strong borders then they're gonna
be vulnerable to the others in this that
same is true through the rest of the
world I mean we've shut down trade a lot
and we've shut down a lot of travel but
how long can we do that we are really
doing a lot of damage to society in the
economy with the shutdown yeah and I
guess that then brings the question of
you know we now know to some degree
what's worked and what hasn't up until
this point there's definitely open
questions about moving forward but if we
had the benefit of 2020 I'm kind of
hindsight what should the US have done
differently to prevent getting in this
situation that we're in it well so
that's just standard thing obviously if
we had taken a seriously early on we
would have just shut down travel from
the you know affected areas and of
course built up resources including
testing and not over regulated these
things which is what hurt us right at
the beginning so I mean I think the
consensus is pretty clear on what we did
wrong and what we could have done with
hindsight but maybe it's not so helpful
now and then you've been a big proponent
of kind of this Plan B in the the
finance or Bitcoin world that plan B is
considered Bitcoin but in the pandemic
world this plan B and I may pronounce
incorrectly but it's Vera Latian very
audacious variolation so tell explain
what that is and kind of why you've been
talking about so we've been talking so
far about these two scenarios one you
you keep it locked down and
you squash it enough that you can manage
that or it goes to most everyone so it's
look we've been looking bad for a while
about the first option the ability to
keep a squash down lovely certainly
everywhere so what happens under Plan B
where it goes most everywhere the
question is how can we minimize the
damage there what can we do
sorry I'm just gonna ink your file we've
got all day you can water as you need
anyway so if it goes most everywhere how
can we minimize the damage so there's a
number of considerations there the first
standard one is don't overload the
medical system spread it out over time
and that means some degree of lockdown
but it not nearly as much as if you're
trying to squash it contain this thing
but people do overestimate the value of
medicine so that's a bit much what else
can we do we could make sure that the
young were the ones initially exposed
more than the old because they have much
lower death rate from this so we need to
get some level of herd immunity which
might be you know some roughly half the
population but why not have it be the
young half the healthy half rather than
the old and sick half and that that's
also capable of dramatically reducing
the death rate and then we could try to
make sure that people were deliberately
infected just so we can control when and
where it happened so most of the
lockdown is to present prevent a tiny
fraction of us from infecting others the
tiny fraction who are at the moment
infected but since we don't know who's
who were locking down everybody if you
deliberately infected some people at a
controlled location and time then you
could isolate them there and you know
use your isolation resources far more
effectively and it also allows you to
spread out the medical resources over
time you can choose to stay do it
earlier than the peak or later than peak
right so just the idea of deliberate
infection if we're going to mostly all
get an exposed has those substantial
advantages you know get the young and
healthy and get you know the control of
the isolation resource but in addition
to these advantages there's apparently
a prospect a very likely prospect that
there are big advantages in how
someone's infected so for most viruses
we know there are a dose effect that is
the initial dose that you get of the
virus matters a lot so for example if
there's a droplet in the air how many
viruses are in that droplet or how many
droplets do you breathe in the first few
minutes where you're getting infected
it's a tiny droplet with very few
viruses that's a low dose you know you
touch a door hot knob an hour after
somebody else touched it then that may
also be a low low dose but if you get
infected say at home by kissing your
infected spouse you're gonna get a big
dose and we've have a lot of data on
other diseases that show low doses can
have much lower morbidity and mortality
you get hurt a lot less and in fact
before we have vaccines we were using
variolation
in particular for smallpox so for
example in the United States during the
Revolutionary War u.s. troops in Canada
were hit by smallpox and devastated and
that's why basically the Canada's a
separate country because those crew
troops couldn't fight the war there
George Washington was worried about this
and even though Continental Congress had
outlawed very Latian intentional
infection at low doses he ordered it for
the US troops anyway in secret so that
the enemy wouldn't attack while they
were sick and basically this reduced the
death rate from smallpox from twenty to
thirty percent down to one to two
percent and that allowed us to win the
Revolutionary War is to worry that if we
did this there's too much societal
pressure or like the headlines of hey
the way to solve this is to actually
intentionally infect people with low
dosage and and we just can as a society
even if the science shows that it's
effective we can't get there because
there's so much fear and uncertainty in
kind of the press or do you feel like
it's actually viable that we could do
this so there's a difference between we
all deciding to do it together as a
joint policy enforced and some of us
deciding to do it because we want to so
we don't there are many problems with
the pandemic that we need to do
everything together
there are collective problems but this
isn't one of them if we have a low dose
way to get infected and we allow some
people get infected that way that helps
and we don't have to require them or
even agree together that we should we
just have to allow it so and in fact
people are in a sense allowed to get
infected but the problem is the people
who would supply the infection aren't
allowed to supply it because of
regulations of drugs and medical ethics
experiments so actually the current
limitation is that we would just need a
hundred or so people to just do a small
trial and we can't get medical ethics
approval to do those small experiments
because the people who run an ethics
experiment say this is unethical because
in their calculation the benefit to
society of finding a way to lower our
death rate by a factor of 10 it doesn't
count the only thing that counts is
these people might by getting attracted
yes that can get hurt and that's just
the rule but in that trial those people
would be opting into this right this man
to your point that's not allowed so on
medical ethics calculations say we're
not allowed to let people volunteer now
of course that's against our practice in
the military and for firefighters and
police there's lots of people in our
society who we allow to take risks for
us and we pay them but the medical
ethics interpretation is that's not to
be allowed to people who take medical
experiments that's just their decision
of what ethics is and they are not
budging in this crisis I mean it sounds
pretty ridiculous right I immediately
thinking of I saw a video online in a
prison where prisoners were basically
gathered in a circle and what it was
being described and of course we don't
know with a hundred percent certainty
but was being described in the video is
that they were one of them was positive
for coronavirus and they were actually
trying to infect each other so that they
could get out eight which sounds pretty
ridiculous but basically you're talking
about he's a much more medically driven
or sign
typically even version of that no Lucas
right so the key problem with people
just getting infected in that way first
is they're not getting a low dose or
trying to make sure that they're getting
a low [ __ ] but also they're not being
isolated and preventing it from
spreading so what I recommend is
something that I called a hero hotel you
you go there you pay to go there and
then they immediately infect you and
keep you there until you're recovered
and so you're not inflaming the whole
pandemic you are just getting this
treatment and getting past it now you
know people may well want to do that for
many reasons
so not just wanting to help society to
get us all past this but they themselves
could get back to work afterwards and
get back to socializing and we get back
to their lives and you know they're many
people are really quite frustrated at
being locked down so I've heard many
people say informally that they sure
wish they could find a way to just get
past this and they'd be willing to take
some risks but what we'd like to do is
to have them have a much lower risk by
doing it deliberately and all we need is
some small trials and see unfortunately
the problem is if people can sit in a
circle with an infected person and try
to get them that's legally allowed but
we are not legally allowing doctors say
to do something like this because the
treatment hasn't been medically approved
and as a company you couldn't sell
people something that let them be
affected with the low dose because that
hasn't been approved by regulators and
so we're in this sad situation where
you'd legally be allowed to do the worst
thing but not the better things because
you know we holding basically these
companies and professionals to much
higher standards than we hold
individuals yeah and this I think goes
to some of the opening the economy
conversation right of like I've for a
while now I've been saying look if
you're sick older have pre-existing
conditions stay inside open up the
economy allow people to go back on a
optional basis protect the people who
aren't comfortable doing that right so
don't let them get fired don't let them
get kind of docked pay or anything like
that but ultimately use like influential
leadership to get people to go back to
work by opting in to doing that
understanding the risk that they're
taking understand how people who think
we're gonna contain this are terrified
by that they say no no you're accepting
the idea that this is gonna go most
everywhere and of course you they may
well notice that we don't very well
isolate the old so you know with a
strategy like that there's a choice how
much dice like the older me if you are
old person living with the young do we
make you move out move somewhere else
with only old people those are
completely reasonable questions but
nevertheless I think the key point is
that that even saying that suggest to
them that you have given up on the the
strategy of containing this which they
are very emotionally committed to
committed to so I like this analogy of
the monkey trap so if there are places
in the world where people try to catch
monkeys and probably eat them and to
catch a monkey one way to do it is you
take a gourd which is a empty shelf of a
vegetable and you put a nut inside it
which is the thing monkeys really like
and it rattles around and the monkey
sees that there's a nut in there and the
monkey puts the hand in the board puts
the hand around the nut and tries to
pull the hand back out but now can't get
it out this the neck because their hand
is bigger with enough and apparently
they won't let go of his nut and you can
catch them and eat them now so that's
this metaphor for things that are so
attractive that by trying to grab on to
it and not letting go you can suffer a
lot more damage than you would if you
just let go other nut and say I'm not
gonna get it and so I fear that's what's
happening and going to happen here with
containing Kovach you know this hope of
containing it it's so attractive and so
emotionally compelling and you feel
Laurel right about that and those people
who are doing it seem like evil
capitalists who only care about money or
whatever that people will not let go and
of course that's gonna cost the most in
the places where we aren't doing very
well at containing it but are doing well
enough still to give you hope yeah it's
super interesting how does this affect
institutions like you spent a bunch of
time thinking about institutions in our
society how does the virus you know my
inclination is entire times when the
buyer is kind of exposed a lot of shams
in society
but how do you see institutions one
weathering this storm and then to coming
out of it on the other end well so
institutions are really pretty stable
most of the time and it requires either
a big crisis and where people lose faith
or some big opportunity and an
entrepreneur like pushes for that
opportunity in order to change his
substitutions right so I mean our taxi
institutions weren't in a crisis but
uber still decided to do a revolution
and that was more opportunistic but
other times like World War one or two
after a big crisis we say what did we do
wrong and we try to reform some
institutions so this crisis will
certainly be available as a resource for
people who are going to advocate for
changes but of course they're not going
to just universally look for the best
institutional changes they will advocate
for whatever changes they already wanted
and look for some sort of a story to to
make that connection so that's what you
should watch out for is people trying
and so that's typically always has in
the crisis people fight enormous Lee
over the story of what went wrong and
therefore the story of who should be
rewarded and what changes should be made
for the better
those stories aren't always correct you
can look at a lot of historical big
changes that were made and the stories
that were told at the time and you go
back and you find out those stories were
pretty distorted picture of what was
going on but they were compelling enough
story that got a lot of people to back a
change so you know we should watch out
for people telling sloppy stories about
what went wrong here and therefore what
what fixes should be created right like
any some people even say well if we had
single-payer health care then all these
people out there losing their jobs are
still have health care that's why we
need some single-payer health care code
we chose and you know it's kind of a
weak connection right but people will be
eager for these stories and really
brings us to what I think is one of the
biggest problems fear is busto
worries are being based on data that are
questionable at best right so you know I
continue to ask people how what
percentage of the American population is
infected
we don't really know right we've got
guesses we've got estimations but we
don't know even the death rate the
people who are arguing is under
accounting there's people who are
arguing it's over accounting right and
so how do we make good decisions with
maybe inaccurate data or questionable
data and then at the Institute in
Louisville when you layer in all of the
agendas that these institutions have how
do you kind of think through that
decision-making process well so those of
us who specialize in designing
institutions try to come up with
institutional variations that are robust
to these details if you need to know
these level of details this fast and
this precisely you're kind of lost and
needing to do institutional changes
because you rarely know that much that
details you're looking for robustness in
your institutions and that's exactly
what we should be doing here we should
be not trying to make these
institutional choices to pend us so much
on these details we want to say so for
example you know early on the CDT
really screwed up the test you might say
well what's this robust solution to that
the robust solution is to not have them
so much control over the test to let a
lot of different people do different
tests and you know go wrong fine but
that's you know a robust solution
relative to saying well who should run
the CDC next time to make and what
methods should they use what procedures
should they have in order to decide this
better well that's not a robust solution
that's saying that's trying to make a
choice that depends a lot of parameters
who should be put in charge well that
depends on a lot of different things
about who they are and what the problem
is right I don't want to solve our
problems in the world by agreeing on who
we should put on charge right so for
example a lot of people want to blame
this all on Trump and there's no doubt
Trump has a lot of things to blame for
but if you're gonna solve the problems
we've had with kovat by replacing Trump
I think you're missing the larger more
institutional problems you know we're
placing any one person just can't do
that much of the of the fixing yeah it's
super interesting one of the other ideas
that you've had
that you've gotten a lot of notoriety
for his work on prediction markets I
think you've actually said that
prediction markets is out of all the
ideas that you've brought kind of Ford
it is your best or your favorite let me
talk just a little bit about the work
that you've done there and then we could
talk through various aspects of pressure
markets kind of impact
sure so the key idea here is that when
we make bad choices it's mostly because
we don't know they're bad choices or
more fundamentally we don't all together
know they're bad choices
so sometimes we make a choice than
you
as of its making these bad choices
so the fundamental policy problem is how
can we collect the information we all
have about the consequences of our
choices so that we can all pull it
together into a form that we can share
and use and if you look at the various
kinds of institutions we've ever used in
the world to collect information and
share it together into a consistent form
that we can use together the institution
that seems to consistently work the best
is speculative markets betting market
stock markets currency markets commodity
markets these markets have consistently
take in given people the incentive to
find things out bring the information
that have to bear to this Center which
is the market include their information
in the current market price and then
allow that current market price to be
information spread everywhere that tells
us all what we all know so we've had
many tests where we have had a betting
market or speculative market price
compared at the same time to other
institutions that we often use like
committees or expert surveys or all
sorts of other mechanisms and basically
we have many dozens of these comparisons
and consistently what we find is that
either they're both about the same in
terms of the accuracy of their forecasts
or the betting market is substantially
better more accurate
that's the consistent data we have now
we have some good theoretical reasons
for understanding why but I don't want
to make the pitch here to be based on
that theory it seems safer to make the
pitch based on the empirics consistently
these betting market prices beat now you
can understand in the sense that what
they do is they offer a challenge to
anybody they say look at my price if you
think this is wrong come fix it and you
will make money and that's not only true
with respect to sort of base things you
might know about a factory burning down
or something else it's about the
patterns like do prices go up on Mondays
too much do they go down when it rains
too much etc and any pattern you could
find where you can see a mistake in the
market you can make money by bed
on that pattern and making it go away
and that's the powerful incentive the
speculative markets offer and in general
but we've had a specular markers just on
the random topics that have frozen like
the price of gold or IBM but we can make
a spending market on purpose on a topic
you care about say even covin kovat
infections and then get the information
on the question you care about so for
example you have a project with a
deadline you want to know will I make
the deadline typically you ask people on
the project will make the deadline what
you get back is a politically correct
response of whatever the leader wants
you to think which is typically yes
we'll make the deadline and if you say
something else you might get punished
for it you know by that the person
running it for violating their their
dogma but if you have betting markets
with people can bet anonymously then you
tend to get the accurate forecast
so we consistently see that people get
accurate forecasts and more accurate
forecasts when we have betting markets
on things and there's an enormous
potential for this to be applied across
society and institutions especially
through what I call conditional betting
markets or decision markets and I've
given the name future key to sort of
governance that way and the key idea is
that you can bet on the outcome of a
decision conditional in which decision
is made and many markets and that can
basically tell you which decision to
make so my favorite example is firing
the CEO say you have a company CEO
should you keep the CEO or should you
fire them
well usually a board makes that decision
but that's relatively political and it
seems like we make a lot of mistakes
there so the idea is you have a stock
market where people trade on stock and
then you have a stock market where you
let them trade on the stock conditional
on whether or not we keep the CEO we
have two prices the price of the stock
if we keep the CEO the price that stock
if we don't and the difference of those
prices tells us should we keep the CEO
and that would be a straightforward way
to give us advice on a key decision and
we could do that everywhere and so the
bottom line is we have a lot of data on
prediction markets in many different
contexts showing that they basically
work we have a lot of innovations
better ways to make them work better and
new context we have a lot of tests of
those but what we don't have as a lot of
adoption and the key problem is that
they are very politically disruptive so
for example if you think about this
person with a deadline and wanting to
know if he'll make the deadline he can
make a prediction market on them on the
project and that will tell them whether
they or make the deadline but the person
writing the project cares more about
having a good excuse if he fails then
lowering the chance of failing and so
typically a person with the project
deadline their best excuse if they fail
will be to say well things were going
along fine and then at the last minute
something came out of left field no one
could see him coming knock this flat
it's so rare and strange it'll never
happen again so there's no need to hold
anyone responsible here let's just
continue on and the person running the
project wants that to be the excuse and
their boss and even boss's boss wants
that to be the excuse because they all
would look bad if they were in charge of
a project that failed for it's just you
know a reason that could have been
prevented
so if you make a prediction market on
this project you could even do
conditional versions which will tell you
how to make the project more likely to
make a deadline but the key problem is
if the market says you won't make the
deadline it'll tell you long in advance
consistently and then you can't have
this excuse that at the last minute we
were not buy something at all that field
everybody could say look the market told
you you were gonna fail you didn't you
didn't prevent the failure you're at
fault and that's an example of how in
our world political disruption of
prediction markets tends to make people
not want to adopt them that is most
people running projects and running
organizations care more about defending
themselves from lighting than they do
about making the overall organization
work off it - reminds me a lot of the
book super forecasters and would it be
fair to say that you think the stock
market is a prediction market as it
exists in today's form or does it not
fit that definitely it does but the
thing it's predicting is not very easy
to interpret you know it's like if
aliens had a betting market and you
could see the prices in the betting
market but you didn't understand what
the
words were on the BET's then you
wouldn't be able to make much useful
right so the stock market is a bet on
the value of that company but that's a
complicated thing and so it's hard to
apply that insight and information to
other things you care about so the more
that we can make betting and speculative
markets more directly on the things we
care about including especially the
decisions we make the more we useful we
can make and how does this get applied
to government obviously that is like the
ultimate decision-making machine that
probably has them the widest impact on a
citizen's life how do we incorporate the
ideas of a prediction market into that
bureaucratic process well mechanically
it wouldn't be that hard to do
the harder problem is do people want to
so what I recommend is that we start
with small-scale experiments and work
our way up so instead of trying
initially to apply prediction markets to
government we apply them to small clubs
small companies small organizations and
slowly show through a long you know
detailed track record that this works
and in each case try to entice
neighboring organizations and slightly
bigger versions to copy what it seems to
have worked at a smaller scale and then
eventually we could get government so as
you may know government isn't usually
the initiator of a lot of innovations to
society but it tends to belatedly copy
them when something works well enough
elsewhere and so that's probably the
best route to produce innovation as
government is to produce in a similar
innovation in the private sector and
then shame the government in the copy
but in order to inspire people about
what should be eventually possible I do
sometimes describe government
applications to give you a sense of just
how far this could go so for example the
simple simplest thing might be just
there are many government projects with
budgets that lie that is there's an
official budget but then later on
they're gonna come back and ask for some
more money and they didn't admit ahead
of time they wanted that extra money but
they kind of knew so you can have a
betting market on the budget for a
project that says well eventually how
much will this cost and
could even have that conditional if we
adopt this project how much will it cost
eventually and now we can get a more
honest budget on how much things will
cost and of course people who are
pushing these projects now don't want
that to happen because they tend to want
to convince us to adopt their project by
believing it will cost as much as it
really well
now freeways cost more you know all
sorts of NASA projects cost more than
they all initially announced so that's
just one simple example of how you can
use it but these conditional versions of
the market would let us make big key
decisions like you might justify
building a stadium by saying oh look at
all the revenue we'll have if we have a
stadium but we might say well if we
build a city how much revenue will we
really have over these coming years and
then that could be more discipline our
choice of do we build the stadium we
could even do this at the you know
presidential election level we could
have betting markets and say there's the
- a Republican and Democrat you know
what are the outcomes you care about
pandemic deaths war deaths GDP you know
stock market whatever it is even
international respect we could have
betting markets in each of these things
conditional on which candidate is
elected actually today there are betting
markets for which nominee should each
party produce if they want to win the
election so there are many markets on
who will win the election and also on
who will be nominated and you just have
to divide those two numbers to get the
probability of being elected if
nominated so those betting markets could
be much thicker and much more accurate
and then they would give a much stronger
message to each party of who to nominate
of course the parties are pretending
that they really want to win but often
the insiders care more about who's
nominated than who wins so they may not
welcome such things yeah it feels like
there's this very direct conflict
between what the math and the scientific
approach of prediction markets would
tell us works and then the elite
powerful people who have realized
if they can actually prevent the
efficiency in things like prediction
markets from taking hold there is an
opportunity for arbitrage which allows
them to hold on to power and to hold on
to decision-making so that this is yes
but it's far worse than you say this is
true in almost all the organization's we
participated from your homeowners
association to your firm to your church
to schools and all the way up to you
know states and nations in all of these
contexts a leaders present themselves
and justify their actions in terms of
information and analysis of the
consequences of actions so in all of
these contexts the perceptions of which
actions have which consequences is
always very political and it's always
manipulated in order to help
powers-that-be win over their rivals and
that's just the nature of all the
organizations were part of so say most
CEOs even might present themselves or
managers as a scientific analyst they've
got a spreadsheet and they're
calculating the costs of this and the
benefits of that and they're talking to
people that get more numbers to put in
this spreadsheet and that's their job
it's to make this spreadsheet and figure
out what to do that's the presentation
for most managers in terms of what their
job is and so that means they're
committed to this idea that I want
information and so if you ask them hey
do you want more information they got to
say yes but they don't mean it
what they want is information they can
massage and control to create the
impression they want and they are very
attentive and careful to to support
information that will support their
narrative and to resist information that
won't in all organizations all people
anywhere if you don't do that you don't
last very long at these levels basically
everybody has to be doing that they all
have to be giving lip service to
information but in fact in most
organizations they don't try very hard
to collect information and they don't
very much what objective information
they want information that they can
control so so many organizations for
example hire consultants to give them
advice but they don't just ask hey
answer this question they ought
typically give them
strong hints about what answers they
want to hear so that they can use that
as a supporting you know some argument
they're trying to make and that's just
the nature of all organizations so it
means that if we could force our
organizations to pay more attention to
objective sources of information then of
course they could make better decisions
but and they all get lip service to that
but they all know that in their struggle
with their rival if they can just allow
some out of control source of
information then they might well lose to
the rival so if they have the upper hand
on the sources of information they very
much want to control it I mean it's you
know most dictators say want to control
the news media and they want to control
the schools as major sources of
information in the population that could
threaten them if they were in someone
else's control it's fascinating to me
that you get this balance between
science and math with power and control
right and it just feels like we take a
approach where those in power benefit
from most of the society not
understanding the power of a prediction
market not understanding like kind of
the math you know again this is far more
general like pretty much all societies
in history you know powerful people have
wanted to control and manage information
processes news processes credentialing
processes authority processes if the
religion is is the source of authority
that people rely on for information
about what's good then they want to
control religion all the way down the
line science today also you know is that
science wants to present itself as
neutral and independent from all these
authority he's just telling you the
truth and sometimes they do that but
less often than they claim and so they
keep you know question is how can we
create a neutral informative source of
information that's been a long difficult
problem but prediction markets in some
sense solve that problem but they don't
solve the more meta problem of how can
you make it anybody want them or care
once you know that you do have
this independent objective source of
information who will wants it or allow
it yeah one of the things so well Lauren
obviously was kind enough to to
introduce us and and he said to me that
you would have fantastic ideas around
extraterrestrial life in a lien and one
of the questions that I asked is if they
believe aliens exist or not so maybe
let's start there just on how you think
about any sort of intelligent life form
outside of of earth ok so if you just go
right to basics the universe is enormous
and it's been around for a very long
time and we're just on one tiny little
corner so if you just went to basics and
said what's the plausibility there there
might be life
intelligent life even somewhere else you
gotta get you got to put it high there's
just no way you can't say that's got to
be high but then you have to confront
that initial plausibility with some data
and then ask what do we conclude after
we've considered the data so the one in
your face biggest piece of data is the
fact the universe looks empty and debt
everywhere everywhere we've seen I mean
if there's there's a lot of activity out
there but none of it looks organized
intelligent purposeful it's just dead on
vast enormous scale I mean there's vast
energy wasted even quasars are sending
out piles and piles of energy that just
gets thrown away and so that is the
spectacular fact about the universe
which says that all these intelligent
lives that might be out there they
haven't reached that level of impact
they haven't reached the scale of doing
big things that we would even notice
from here they may be out there and
doing big things on their local scale
but they does not let and that's
puzzling because there's been billions
of years here it's not like there's been
a time shortage they've had plenty of
time I mean most likely there were
aliens many billions of years before us
right you know we
it's now 13 billion years since the
beginning 14 and so you know they were
just four billion years ago and that's
lots of time so what the hell why is it
also dead men peace so we struggle to
come up with some stories there but
that's got to constrain what whatever
they are whatever they're doing
apparently they have not reached this
massive scale and it's a court you know
you might think well they have this rule
that they don't mess with things or they
don't want to be they're hiding but it's
really hard to enforce rules on really
large scales right you're talking about
like way out there say a whole galaxy
that would be filled with aliens and
they've got this rule that none of them
get early ever leave the galaxy to go
somewhere else and mess with things like
how could they enforce like a border on
a galaxy and make sure nobody ever
leaves I mean it's just mind-boggling
the sort of coordination and control
that would be required to prevent spread
and becoming visible and on cosmic
scales so but that doesn't mean they
aren't there somewhere and it doesn't
mean they couldn't come here either but
now if you think okay
could they be here could they be around
here you say well we have to confront
again the data point that they're not
obvious around here right they don't
have shining cities in the sky floating
over us right
they haven't remade the weak rings of
Saturn whatever I mean they're not
visible and we are right I mean we are
pretty visible we aren't visible maybe
for a thousand light years but we're
visible around here so if they're around
here they are surprisingly invisible
that's also kind of puzzling I mean you
know the things that might lead you to
prevent you from becoming cosmically
visible don't necessarily prevent you
from being locally visible if you're
around I mean you could certainly have a
little city a little facility some mines
some production
some whatever right maybe you do fight a
war every once in a while and you make a
big splash where you slap each other I
mean you know these things would be
visible so question it's like well how
do we understand that that hypothesis
what what I mean how much do we need to
degrade the scenario by saying this
can't happen then we have to turn to
think oh what scenarios could there be
possibly that would be consistent with
not only they're not visible in the
cosmic table they're also around here
and not visible on the smaller scale and
then the third data point that you might
try to take into account is to say well
they're not entirely invisible locally
because there's all these reports of
people who say they see them and now you
think well you know they've been around
for billions of years there and no
they've got to be enormous ly capable
technologically because that's the only
thing consistent with this age and
distance they could have traveled and
they could just I guess if they wanted
to just completely hide and they could
make themselves really visible but no
they're right on this end of visibility
and apparently they're smart enough to
know that's where they are it's on
purpose somehow they are just being kind
of barely visible like what's with that
what what possible purpose or planner or
set of constraints could lead to this
combination of these three facts again
they didn't give rise to vast visible
stuff in the universe they don't even
give rise to much dramatically visible
on here but they're giving rise to a
small amount of barely visibility like
what the hell so I guess part of this is
like shouldn't we be more concerned of
them finding us than them finding them
who gets discovered or infiltrated they
end up being the loser and the
engagement and so should we be worried
about that
well again the key thing we have to be
very confident about aliens is that they
are vastly more capable than us on
pretty much any margin so if they
weren't they wouldn't really be alien so
you could imagine like say there was a
dinosaur civilization deep under the
earth I mean it's a crazy scenario right
but at least they would have shared a
history with us right they would have
come from a similar origin and have
similar back-and-forth interaction and
then you expect a correlation of their
capabilities and ours and their
interests and ours and even the
conflicts but aliens sort of by
definition they don't share this recent
origin and interaction they just have a
very distant origin and so by definition
they they just came from a far away from
long ago and that right there tells you
their capabilities have to be vastly
larger than ours so if there's you know
they're vastly more likely to learn
about us than we before we learn about
them there's just very little chance
that could be otherwise if there's any
degree of them looking around and us
looking around they're gonna see us
before we see them
full-stop end of story there's just you
know in this contest there is no contest
I mean they are just vastly beyond us
the only advantage we could possibly
have is this apparent advantage that
they must think it's not an advantage of
being noisy and doing stuff and this is
the visibly active when they're
apparently really tidy it is wild to
think through what is out there and and
kind of what that impact on us could be
before we finish up I always asked
everybody what uh what's the most
important book that you've ever read
well that's tough because I think for
most people there are times when they
read a book and it's really insightful
for them but that was a coincidence
about where they were and what they knew
and if somebody else had read a
different book at a different time you
know would be less insightful so for
example at one point I read the book by
Hugh Everett about the many more
interpretation when I was sitting in a
library in the University of California
Irvine and that was very influential for
me because I had never seen any point of
view like that and that was very
dramatic and that really influenced me
at the time later in my life I remember
reading Herbert Simon's you know art
sciences of the artificial which
explained a whole bunch of views but of
course you could by now get those views
some more from somewhere else
twenty years ago Joffrey Miller's the
mating mind was influential for me I had
a bunch of concepts about evolutionary
psychology but of course you could also
probably get those ideas elsewhere
depending on you know what you read so I
I really I think what you read when
depends a lot on what you already know
so I recommend the same most people just
read a lot of text books if you if
you're young you want to learn a lot
about the world like text books are our
standard way to summarize a lot of
things to put it all together if you
know there's not text books on you
someone is their subject find a review
article that summarizes a bunch of
things and that'll and then what you
already know of course so obviously you
know what books I mean the Bible of
course is very influential for our
culture so when I read the Bible when I
was a kid and no doubt that influenced
me a lot how could it dot spending that
much time involved in this one book or
framing it but um I don't know if I can
point to that many things now but no
doubt it's influential so I guess I'm
not that big a fan of the influential
book question yeah well I couldn't agree
with you more in terms of when you read
a book is almost as important as what
the book actually is like I couldn't
agree with that more your idea about
reading textbooks is really interesting
in that I think the more we go into this
digital world the more people want kind
of the information delivered digitally
but we forget that the whole point of
the textbook is to teach people about a
subject okay and that's good all
textbooks right but it's more about a
systemic thing right pick a subject and
let somebody walk you through a system
rather than just grabbing a blog post
here and a tweak there and you know a
news article there and just piling these
things up randomly I definitely think
people are way too into the news so the
time to pay attention the news is where
it's affecting your life and maybe where
your expertise is now at the moment
where you can say something to the world
but mostly you want to learn about stuff
not because it's in the news at the
moment you just want to learn about the
fundamental important stuff in the world
what what's going on what are the key
issues and at any one moment you could
decide which subject you're interested
in and maybe something will spark an
interest but you know use even a news
article as a question ask question do I
want to spend a month now diving into
this subject and really learning a lot
about it is this news article so
intriguing that that's what I want to do
that's that's a pretty high standard you
can't do that for most news articles of
course but maybe that's the best
question to ask about a news article is
this a hint that this subject is worth
just diving way into yeah I think that's
really really good advice where can we
send people to to get in contact with
you learn more about your work find your
books and everything else well I'm on
webpages handsome Dutch EMU de edu and
I'm on Twitter
at Robin Hanson blog overcoming bias and
so you know you'll get more than enough
of those places we could use many many
more people like you because I think
that there's a there's a lot of bias
there's a lot of paying attention to the
news right now and frankly I think the
world would be a better place if we
could get get people to kind of go back
to first principles thinking and sound
decision me one last recommendation that
I people liked what I did the same
Harris interview which is to say try not
to have as many opinions people feel
this need to have an opinion on every
subject that comes up people talk about
and most of those opinions aren't very
well thought out and so not helping very
much pick your area of specialty what
you're gonna really learn about and know
well tell us your opinions in that area
and then I want to listen and defer to
you when it's not matter
I want to defer to other people who
specialized in most of the topics and I
want to pick a small set of topics which
are the ones that I think I specialized
in
to be worth having my own opinions I
think that is a very intelligent and
prescient way to to look at the world so
listen Robert I really appreciate you
doing this this is fantastic I think
people will learn a lot from this and
and hopefully we can drive some people
to let's check out more of your work I
think that we could just benefit from
more people thinking like you and kind
of consuming the content that you're
putting out there so well from everyone
else just thank you and the fun chatting
and enjoy the rest of your day
absolutely and thank you til Iran
obviously for all for making the
introduction as well